foreign
[Music]
your country shares a border with Russia
you're a member of NATO how has the war
in Ukraine changed thinking in Norway
well I would say fundamentally like in
other European countries and especially
bordering countries that we wake up and
and learn that our neighbor has attacked
another neighbor massively
and as we have seen since February uh
basically
aiming at destroying
uh buildings workplaces
infrastructure driving millions of
people escaping it is a fundamental
change to the whole European landscape
so yes it is it is crucial our neighbors
Sweden and Finland have been outside
NATO decided quickly that they wanted to
be in NATO
we don't have a perceived direct threat
at our border like what we have seen in
Ukraine but of course we are taking
measure to safeguard our security
I mean you said in the past that Russia
and Norway have been at peace for more
than a thousand years do you think there
is a direct threat to Norwegian
territory or perhaps to Norwegian
infrastructure coming from Russia
afterwards Russia has demonstrated in
Ukraine nobody can can hide away that
question you know deny it again you know
Russia has moved both people and
military equipment from the north to
Ukraine
so we observe that and we don't observe
direct attention at our border but of
course we we follow developments in our
near abroad we sail our Navy we fly our
petrol planes to to monitor the
situation and we do that very closely
with our Nordic Partners but also with
our NATO parties so when we now put the
major emphasis on securing our
infrastructure we do that as Norway and
we do that in close cooperation with our
allies and partners and first among them
with Germany you're here in Berlin for a
security conference uh and for talks
with the German government let's talk
about NATO's stance is it the right one
providing technical support uh but
waiting essentially for Ukraine to win
the war on its own that might take a
very long time is it the right approach
well you know this this is not a war
against NATO territory but close to Nato
territory and Ukraine is a free
Democratic nation that deserves support
and I think both Norway and Germany made
a very historic decision back in
February to to offer military equipment
to a country at War and we have done so
in Norway we have not done that since
the 1950s and and you know we now
provide
military equipment that is Ukraine's
right to defend itself and it is our
right to help Ukraine defend itself but
but again I think you know it will it
will be irresponsible to kind of pull
NATO into this uh conflict as it stance
but to support Ukraine and to do
everything we can that this war should
stop and it should stop by stopping
Russian aggression Ukraine has the right
to defend itself
what should be the consequences for
Russia from its aggression should it be
more isolated do you think in the future
and should indeed Ukraine be brought
more closely into uh if you like the
Western Alliance well Ukraine has its
European track towards membership of the
European Union which is of course a
pretty long exercise but I think that's
a good good sign
Russia is hit by Major economic
sanctions which I I I know they they
must have expected that this was made
very clear from from countries around
that if you revert to open war against
neighboring country it will have
consequences so Norway has been
supporting all of those packages from
the European Union you know aligning
ourselves with them
then we have to lift and our perspective
and look ahead you know there will be a
day after this conflict and Russia will
not go away and we have to think about
the European security structure where
countries can live side by side and
having a political toolbox where we if
there are problems we deal with them
politically and not by War but right now
it's about you know helping Ukraine to
survive
as a result of the war after the closure
of the nordstream one pipeline Norway is
now the largest exporter of gas to uh to
Germany into Western Europe
um we've seen those explosions on the
gas pipelines in the Baltic are you
worried about those direct threats to
that energy infrastructure
well it would be naive to say that it
has no meaning you know it of course it
is an extraordinary sign that uh
obviously this has been sabotaged
against the north stream pipeline
although they were not operating with
gas
um so Norway has high security around
our infrastructure we've had that for
many many years we have increased that
security since February
so we have a close cooperation between
police and defense we have an increased
surveillance along the whole system you
know we have three major land
installations
we have 90 platforms out there on the
shelf and we have about 9 000 kilometers
of Pipelines
but I can assure you we look after them
pretty closely and we do that also now
with our allies so alongside for example
Germany United Kingdom France
Netherlands we sail more actively
together and the chancellor and I we we
have agreed that you know this issue
about safeguarding infrastructure is
also a NATO issue so we will propose
tornado allies that this is something we
should look into coordinate our efforts
because critical infrastructure is key
to security okay High Energy prices have
boosted the profits for sales of uh
Norwegian oil and gas
um and there have been calls from
countries like Germany for lower prices
or something to be done about it is that
a fair request I think is a very fair
request to hope for lower prices of
energy and I can tell you it is not in
Norway's interest that you have high and
volatile Energy prices in Europe I'll
give you three examples for that high
gas prices in Europe means very high
electricity prices in Norway and in
families in Norway they Heat their
houses with electricity so that's a
direct negative sign secondly uh
Europe's industry is Norway's partner
you know we have to work with them so
problem for European industry is problem
for our industry and thirdly these
Energy prices creates social unrest
which is not good for us as partners and
NATO allies so we will do everything we
can to support measures to stabilize
markets and bring prices down but the
reasons why prices are high is that
there is a shortage of energy
because Russian gas is no longer there
so we have done everything we can to
increase our sales so gas we've
increased them by almost 10 percent to
the maximum
but then we have to move on with Europe
to produce more energy and they will
have to come from renewable sources from
offshore wind from solar from Land wind
and from hydrogen and all these issues
are on the agenda when we now meet with
Germany the Norwegian government's still
selling licenses for more oil and gas
exploration in the North Sea uh you're
promoting that is that compatible with
the goal of reducing CO2 emissions and
reducing emissions getting away from
fossil fuels in future we must get away
from fossil fuels and and we have
targets of killing emissions from our
shelf by 50 by 2030. we have to go into
carbon capture and storage if we're
going to restart climate objectives
worldwide we have to move forward on
that
um
Norway is looking after potential gas
founds in the North Sea close to our
existing insulation close to where there
is activity but we are moving into a
future where that production will go
down and in parallel we will have
increase of offshore wind production
floating offshore wind production which
is a technologically very Advanced
operation so gradually you will see that
we are going through this change
together and we will be producing
renewable energy for Norway and for uh
contribute contributing to Europe final
question you're here in berlinville the
Berlin security conference what can
these kind of gatherings achieve is even
more coordination and cooperation
between the Western Partners needed at
this time yes and I mean I I think one
Vision that President Putin may have had
was that the Western cohesion would fall
apart it has not happened although you
know there is pain coming from The
Economic Consequences
the biggest pain in Ukraine of course I
mean it's extraordinary what what they
are now having to take but for all of us
it's it's the mounting times but the
cohesion is very strong so these these
conferences I think are important to
compare notes to sit down and and look
into what we can do together we have to
continue to support Ukraine in the
budget that I've presented for 2023 I'm
announcing that Norway early next year
will announce a major
a multi-year package for Ukraine where
we will take some of the
benefits we've had from energy exports
and and look at where is the source of
this it comes from what happened in
Ukraine and we will also be stepping up
our Aid to the countries Beyond Europe
that are now suffering from high food
prices High Energy prices and for all of
this to work we have to coordinate
ourselves you cannot be kind of 50
different initiatives and and for Norway
coordinating with Germany is a key part
of that strategy prime minister thank
you very much thank you